when we say to
ourselves you must go on the reason is
you
see that we are not living in the
Eternal
now where reality
is we are always thinking that the
satisfaction of life will be coming
later don't kid
yourself only
suckers put hope in the future
there isn't much of a future you're
going to
die so therefore this hope for the
future it is a hoax it's a perfect
hoax because you're not fully Alive
now you think maybe someday you will
be look supposing I ask you what did you
do
yesterday most people say well I got up
at 7:30 and I brushed my
teeth and I read the newspaper over a
cup of
coffee and then I looked at the clock
and dressed and
uh got in the car and drove down toown
and did this and that in the office and
so on and you go on and on and on and
you suddenly discover that what you've
described has absolutely nothing to do
with what
[Music]
happened you've described a fleshless
list of
abstractions whereas if he were actually
aware of what went
on you could never describe
it because
nature is multi-dimensional language is
linear language is
scrawny and therefore if you identify
the world as it is with the way the
world is described it's as if you were
trying to eat dollar bills and expect a
nutrition ious
diet or eat numbers a lot of people eat
numbers people play the stock market and
doing nothing but eating
numbers and they're always unhappy
absolutely miserable because they never
get
anything so therefore they always hope
more is
coming because they believe that if they
eat enough dollar bills eventually
something satisfactory will
happen so eating the abstractions all
the time we want more more more
time confucious very wisely
said a man who understands the da in the
morning may die with content in the
evening because when you
understand you don't put your hope in
time time won't solve a thing
and the Christian word for
sinning in Greek is
amatan which means to miss the
point and the point is eternal life
which is here and
now but until there is silence of the
mind it is almost impossible to
understand
eternal life that is to say Eternal
now when you are fully aware and not
thinking you will notice some amazing uh
absences there is no
past can you hear anything past
incidently can you hear anything
future they're just not there to the
plain sense of one's
ears well I remember in The Sermon on
the Mount that Jesus said
[Music]
them a lot of things about this consider
the lies of the field how they grow they
toil not neither do they spin and yet
suan in all his glory was not clothed
like one of
these and if God so clothe the grass of
the field which today is and tomorrow is
cast into the oven shall he not much
more clothe you faithless
ones wow
so do not worry about tomorrow saying
what shall we eat what shall we drink or
how shall we clothe ourselves oh the
Rabel seeks after these
things sufficient to the day is the
worry of
it nobody ever preaches a sermon on that
text never I've Heard lots of
sermons and never one on that one
because people
say look that's all very well because
Jesus was the boss's
son and and he knew you see that he was
really in charge of the universe and he
nothing to worry
about but we have to be
practical
oh what do you suppose the gospel was
the good
news do you know it never got out
[Laughter]
[Music]
you too are the boss's
son that was the
Gospel lots of people in India know that
perfectly well when you get to be a
certain age and after you studied long
enough with a certain Guru then and then
only may you realize this if you've put
in the time they finally let you
in here you have to wait until you
dead the only place to begin is
now because here's where we
are so why put it
off a lot of people say well I'm not
ready what do you mean you're not ready
what do you have to be to be
ready I I'm I'm I'm not good enough I'm
uh perhaps not old enough not mature
enough still I'm frightened of pain I'm
still uh dependent on material things I
have to you know eat a lot and drink a
lot and uh I better get all that under
control
first
oh you you you want to be able to
congratulate yourself for having gone
through the
discipline which is rewarded with
[Music]
realization that is trying to quench
fire with
[Music]
fire wouldn't it be great to have no
fear no attachments no
Hang-Ups to be as free as the
air Let It Be Crazy to have that courage
and you look into yourself honestly and
you find that inside you're actually a
quaking mess of sensitivity running away
from the quaking mess escaping you never
can
there's nothing you can actually
do to
transform your own nature
into
unattached
selflessness because you have a selfish
reason for wanting to do
it what does it mean that you can't do
anything about
it it's singing loud and clear the
reason you can't do anything about it is
that you don't exist
you as you conceive yourself to be that
is your ego your image of yourself isn't
there it doesn't exist it's an
abstraction well when you understand
that you're
liberated there's The Happening the
suchness yes sure you bet but it's not
pushing you around because there's no
you to be pushed around
so the this illusion of the persecuted
ego who is pushed around by Fate is just
altogether disappeared
and so in likewise the illusion of the
ego who pushes fate around is also
[Music]
disappeared there's a
Happening by dying to yourself by having
become completely incompetent and found
that you don't exist you're
reborn you become everything in the
words of Sir Edwin Arnold foregoing self
the universe grows ey